I wanted to ask you how you think you'd
cope if you had a robot like the one in
the film I would cope very well because
I would like the idea of something
inanimate cleaning up the dishes in
doing the laundry and doing the
gardening work and taking out the
garbage that's all I would ever use a
robot for his menial tasks I would never
think that I would have one that would
replace the relationship I would have
with a woman or my children or my family
how did it work on set because Peter
Sarsgaard plays the voice of variable
doesn't he so what were you kind of
acting with when you're on screen acting
with a piece of metal that sometimes had
a human inside most of the time didn't
because the set was small and
extraordinarily hot so whenever we had a
small young woman inside she'd faint so
it was a you know we thought well it is
the movies let her faint but we'd
finally decided that so sometimes
someone would read the lines off camera
and Peter Sarsgaard I never heard until
you know I saw the movie how was it be
when you actually heard what the robot
sounded like wonderful he's perfect
and also my voice is very deep and
Peters is exist in a kind of Alto place
so I thought the juxtaposition it was
exciting for me having made the movie to
suddenly hear the robot a great cast in
a film Peter Sarsgaard you don't work
where those who said but Susan Sarandon
you do James Morrison as well and Liv
Tyler yeah wonderful group of actors and
it was a difficult film to shoot because
we only had 20 days it was very hot very
very uncomfortable but every actor came
in and did their best job and we became
a family very quickly we had to and
basically on screen for the whole time
aren't he said what was that like oh
it's nice it's better than sitting in
your trailer waiting them waiting for
them to do somebody else's scene you
know it made the time go very quickly
and what's next - you know Frank I'm in
I'm in nice at the moment shooting a
movie called Grace of Monaco
about Princess Grace
you